c'était génial c'était contente de le
faire très content très fier d'être
sorti avec autant de souvenirs autour de
j'ai appris beaucoup de choses tu t'es
fait des amis des trucs
[Musique]
j'aime bien le petit lac qui chantait la
fin là
je l'adore
on voulait revoir avec toi ton portrait
regardez c'est parti Miss c'est
l'autodidacte de la promotion ce qu'elle
aime c'est revisiter des chansons
derrière son piano plus de batterie je
suis dans la merde c'est des rendez-vous
prévus
[Musique]
et depuis son arrivée au château sa
technique vocale force l'admiration de
ses camarades j'ai entendu ta voix
de mes jours
je suis juste
hyper sûre amis ça a trouvé sa place
dans le château en quelques jours elle a
déjà progressé
[Musique]
le Game je dois faire un truc de fou et
je vais être sauvé
[Applaudissements]
j'ai regardé un peu Taratata la semaine
prochaine sur France 2 donc ça devrait
tenir pour TF1 pour la star ensuite
match de rugby donc là ça devrait passer
sous les 3 millions je pense on va
passer aux alentours de 9 3 je crois tu
changes ton non j'ai 10 semaines
prochaines ça va être d'accord semaine
d'après j'ai regardé 3e semaine ça va
être plus compliqué il y a des matchs de
rugby à du rugby de l'équipe de France
sur France 2 ça va être ça va être plus
dur je pense ça peut passer sous les
trois mais ça sera toujours bien sur les
les moins de 50 ans alors on voulait
revenir sur avec toi sur ta PlayStation
lors du prime de samedi qu'est-ce que tu
as chanté à Nice j'ai chanté Rolling In
The Deep d'Adèle j'adore
j'ai longtemps hésité avant de choisir
cette musique mais je me suis dit sur ce
son je vais pouvoir me dépasser on m'a
conseillé avec le directeur tu sais
quand tu es nommé tu vas dans le bureau
et le directeur tu dis ok moi je te vois
bien sur ça ou sur ça
en fait
c'est une musique que j'ai toujours
choisi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
à la santé tu m'oublieras
après c'est voilà c'est l'escalade
douloureux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci beaucoup
c'est un peu le défaut moi je trouve
cette année parce que il y a pas il y a
pas de temps de défauts ils sont tous
très bien
mais c'est un peu le défaut je trouve
cette année euh parce que on va juste
revenir puisque je n'ai je n'ai pas
critiqué la Star Academy revenir sur ce
que tu as dit samedi je voudrais une
parenthèse qui a de faire bien plaisir
mon petit de leurs mots et une quéquette
mais on va voir Twitter on va on va tu
vas me le montrer d'ailleurs il y a deux
choses qui sont pas bonnes choses mais
je reviens de suite
je trouve que le vous avez un très gros
niveau et c'est un peu The Voice au
château et c'est ce que j'ai dit aux
élèves hier soir je leur ai dit parce
que je cache rien je leur dis moi je
suis embêté parce que c'est The Voice au
château et pour moi la Star Academy
c'est une école c'est le collège
Saintes-Marie de Tarbes là c'est la
Sorbonne si vous êtes tous hyper fort
vous savez danser chanter un talon et
c'est un peu le défaut et puis même
quand je t'ai vu arriver je te jure tu
es une star du Diva je te le jure une
star ma chérie donc je vais te dire tu
sens bien c'est un coup pas ça veut rien
moi je te dis si tu cherches producteur
tu m'appelles
[Rires]
je préfère rentrer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
apparemment
ça me fait vraiment plaisir c'est vrai
qu'on a pas de recul quand on est à
l'intérieur
elle est exceptionnelle
de la Sarah je te jure je dis oui tout
de suite c'est que vous n'avez pas vu
l'émission et le problème c'est que
demain m'a dit pendant le magnéto oui
mais comment ça se fait Kelly qu'elle
est sortie elle est hyper bonne mais le
souci c'est qu'ils sont tous hyper bons
donc en fait il est là le problème il y
a pas assez de l'élimination elle est
incroyable parce qu'il y en a un qui a
été sauvé donc Julien et après en fait
c'est les élèves qui votent et c'est
égalité et donc c'est Julien qui a dû
décider entre toi et
et donc c'était une voix en plus une
voix presse
d'ailleurs c'est un super moment de
l'émission j'ai regardé que ça moi
j'adore ça j'adore voir des gens
illuminés
et je suis très content que ce soit la
météo c'est ça devait être dur quand
même c'est très dur mais quand on est
nommé c'est un scénario qui va forcément
se passer à 33%, tu sais que tu peux
sortir sur trois
c'est le jeu mais franchement tu es ta
je te dis toi tu vas voir tu es sorti de
la Star Ac mais tu vas rentrer dans le
cœur des Français je te le dis oui et là
vous avez un discours très politiquement
correct que je comprends mais très
franchement vous dit toute la semaine
que vous êtes génial votre voix est
merveilleuse ça joue à une voix est-ce
que vous ressentez une profonde
injustice d'avoir été éliminé injustice
non parce que il y a pas de tricherie
c'est le jeu on sait qu'il faut une voix
pour l'un une voie pour l'autre
frustration parce que je ne m'attendais
pas à sortir dès la première semaine
mais acceptation parce que c'est le jeu
et on signe pour ça justement pour la
surprise pour les choses inattendues et
je suis sortie avec humilité avec fierté
et j'en veux à personne parce que je
sais que si ça ne tenait qu'à Julien il
aurait pas forcément voté
parce que c'est Julien qui reste à la
fin alors
pas sauvé personne ne veut avoir la
responsabilité de déterminer